huh we weren't here oh okay
[Music]
look at Betty's already I brought my
well it's really cold that's I have to
wear an extra jacket do you remember the
last time I came to Montauk and I got to
a massive
a long time you just stare at it when
you bring the man back know everything
go no she would look at it so much that
it kind of thoroughly crumbling and like
pulling apart isaac is wearing is Mickey
shirts noise a little worried
bring braids if not I would put the hood
on right now
[Music]
my ears
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today we just need one more to check off
of my busy land bucket list which would
be Shanghai we've been to LA Orlando
Paris Japan Hong Kong Sigma's last one
might be right wait happier to be in
disneyland hong kong been hong kong it
though you know deep down it's like we
have here right now Flores is the
Disneyland
hello no one said this we land our land
oh I was trying to like fight the tears
because I was just so happy it was like
my childhood dream come true and then
now being here I'm like I got my ears I
just screw it I'm gonna mess up my hair
[Music]
that's a small castle this castle is so
tiny and it's under construction so you
don't have mean we have to come back to
come back when the castles under you say
you've had enough of our money
[Music]
mañana thank you tomorrow and Cantonese
continuous bland tingly
[Music]
you know it's like they have a man in
the wasp ride because I'm going to be
open until March
yeah for Isaac
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we are now at MacDonald's
camp come to Hong Kong can't go anywhere
without trying to McDonald's and seeing
what regional differences they have and
unique flavors they have to offer our
menu and what unique flavour you endure
that was basic ok I was craving a Big
Mac they may love it yeah what about
that drink
it's a coke you know what I did get
different corn instead of fries am i
eating at meeting other people friends
yeah yeah Isaac actually is way more
adventurous than I am so this meal or
your meal looks kind of blown away all
right so first off so Hong Kong is known
for their milk teeth their lights on and
they actually serve this at their
McDonald's not too bad
very heavy on the cream flavor not too
heavy on the tea flavor but it suffice
as in a moment of need for some milk tea
I also forgot what they called it
Bolognese
[Music]
so there's like what Bolognese meat
sauce some lettuce a mini fried egg
excited about that fries that comes with
a lobster flavor all right first up how
you with never chase bolognese sauce on
a sandwich
now we're I like how stick the penny is
though that's something that you don't
see ya something different the first
bite at where I didn't mix it up it
wasn't very good too strong
oh yeah it was pretty good now you mix
it up
[Music]
like a fishy clearance lobster flavor
alright that's it for McDonald's here in
Hong Kong
peace out buy some against agree to this
restaurant to eat some children is
another morning at Hong Kong and
specifically here because they serve
fish skin I don't think I've ever had
just fished in all right so how do you
eat this pop-up is code that surely it's
not wrong okay all you have to do some
ginger maybe some scallion
[Music]
texture is awesome you can expect that
it's like a jelly chip crunchy I like
jelly like
[Music]
this way is just like
[Music]
right now we're in on things 360 we're
here to see the Big Buddha we did that
last time we all came together but it's
super different this time
yeah so race it owes we have so many
layers on it's freezing up here and the
line was like an eternity and last time
we're here it wasn't like it so I'm just
like cool a different experience last
time we were like sweating her butts off
now we're shimmer our butts off I didn't
know that Hong Kong keep this cold you
know here did I that's like we did not
pack very well with Diana and I went
shopping last night and we went ham we
bought like so many things and we were
so impressed with how great the quality
is and how affordable everything was for
me and so I got this coat and then I got
a whole bunch of other sweaters and I
got this poncho and just so many things
like I want to do like all of the
clothes that I bought here because I
love it so much but it was also really
awesome too because it's keeping us warm
[Music]
Tiny's waffle punch on the outside
souther middle get on my way
[Music]
I was trying to be peaceful up there did
you meditate TIF no no I was trying to
meditate a little bit I was standing and
walking and filming meditating to keep
yourself warm people come here and pray
you shave for health and the wealth both
right and then put Alex right but when
you smell or inhale all this smoke I
don't think you know you're gonna have
good health hanging up
[Music]
[Music]
Oh beautifully themes it's like perfect
best me I'm the year the dragon
you're my mushi
[Music]
you know how to ice-skate kind of okay
take your time
push yourself nice I feel you I cannot
ice skate at all save my life like I'm
just going based on what I know in
theory I can't do it I don't how is it
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so yesterday when we were going up to
the peak no not the peak with the GaN
Yong ping 360 that over there yesterday
was like the coldest coldest day so far
it was the windiest - so I ended up
getting a really bad sore throat and
I've been coughing and so Eamon gave me
some s so now I look like a local it's
like a look
but yeah it's like been so cold and then
we totally didn't pack properly we were
told it was gonna be like LA weather
like when it gets a little bit cold even
wreath like it that way weather 50
degrees or something but it's so windy
and like that windchill factor is
serious like we are all exhausted from
this vacation sound like we need a
vacation from our vacation anyway
today's New Year's Eve is exciting
hi sick so tired is in zombie mode
how you feeling Isaac
good very very tired
[Music]
I know
[Music]
all right experience very traditional
role on enforcing you know strangers
stop boy
and so we are with
[Music]
[Music]
sweepy everyone so tired today
[Music]
so I guess it's like Chinese voodoo that
you're right sound the person you hate
their name on a piece of paper you beat
it
so I guess my brother's gonna do it see
what happens
it's kind of hard to say that you and
hate a particular person just mush a
you're gonna go out
to create a paper around
you know you're doing Thanks so I just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you see what you got
[Music]
TV unupgraded nice to watch don't Ramon
here yeah I remember sitting right there
before and watching tea cartoons come
and carry Alaska channel here that's the
first time yes there's my boss I feel
like I look like my grandpa yeah you do
actually your parents or your
grandparents or your dad looks like I
have one person I've ever met
okay though that won't find it on me huh
[Music]
and please
[Music]
[Music]
oh how cute
oh so cute and now you look like you
have your features I know these pictures
actually son Isaac's baby photos now
nice external phone was ten years ago
it's crazy to see when and where you
came from
you're wearing a yellow jacket and you
have a red scarf thing that looks kinda
like you recreate this photo now you're
looking this way but that's like over
here both of you but they smile in this
photo this is the first time I've seen
you look like your dad
really you guys so much okay that here
now I control it kimete you guys oh my
gosh I thought that containment on you
oh my gosh this looks that way
[Music]
look at their teeth ceremony we just did
this yeah
this window is here so that means you
good you guys did the pony I think so
yeah
that's that door cool we just we just
did the same thing just now that's cool
hello these candid photos of stock
photos lighting and I really 3ds I took
the picture you had a really great model
works I have my own model I do the
camera too
[Music]
best Paris cool your future son was
gonna get married there
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
really kicking in my pistol whatever
like New Year's Eve
[Music]
we're doing for 2019
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
for everything
not only of the tree blocking entire
building is lucky
all right after the countdown we are now
off the drink
Isaak is being babysat
mom dad yeah yeah
and Jerry me too and Nana are wandering
the streets trying to figure out which
bar to go to and the streets are filled
without the table and oh I think they
found a spot to drink let's go check out
what the menu says
[Applause]
[Music]
slimmin really sick like dying sick the
last two days and so I'm gonna drink
this herbal tea here is smells like the
tea I had for my eczema from the
acupuncturist Oh
so you see you shouldn't wanted it yeah
I used to drink this stuff I'm so proud
of you too in Chinese stuff this is
really traditional her while oh yeah
Malone's half white cross drinking teeth
pretty much that's how bad I've been
feeling the last two because the last
two days I just stayed at home why
everyone else went out and I've just
been so miserable like I'm just so tired
of being sick I don't do anything right
now
[Music]